one in five vets in uh of U.S adults 20
to 49 is from excessive drink and study
shows this is a CNN Story the percentage
of debts attributed to alcohol use
variated State varied state by state by
nationally it's a leading cause of
preventable death said lead study author
Marissa Esser who leads the U.S CDC
alcohol program States and communities
can prevent these premature deaths using
evidence-based strategies to reduce
availability and accessibility of
alcohol and increase its price that can
mean increasing taxes on alcohol or
limiting uh where alcohol is sold as or
added the CDC defines moderate drinking
as two drinks or less in a day for men
or one drink or less for women
two-thirds women why they're using women
isn't it like uh it's offensive to use
but anyway two-thirds of adults reported
report drinking more than moderate
amounts at least once a month Adam so
this is one of those stories that I had
kind of had to read twice I'm like what
is what are they trying to say here and
the the first thing I thought of when
they said reduce the availability and
accessibility of alcohol it's like yeah
we tried that one time before it was
called prohibition how'd that work out
yeah not so good okay that's not gonna
happen all right we're now we're gonna
start increasing the taxes on alcohol
price top
increasing taxes and alcohol and
limiting where alcohol is sold it's like
how many like
like I've been in The Nightlife business
and and I go out all that kind of stuff
like that it's like you go to a liquor
store what's the average bottle cost 30
40 50 bucks okay now if you want to go
buy that same exact bottle of Club
that's gonna cost you 300 400 500 bucks
if you want to buy it per drink that's
10 12 bucks per drinkers it's like
whatever you do to go and try to figure
out the price or the cost of the taxes
like people are gonna drink you're not
gonna figure that out people are not
gonna stop drinking people are not gonna
stop partying by the way especially
during a recession hello
whatever ideas you have to limit people
from drinking not gonna happen however
let me give you the other side of coin
where I think that this this idea can be
implemented is harsher penalties for
DUIs
it amazes me I live in South Beach it
amazes me that there is not a DUI
checkpoint every single weekend leaving
South Beach it's it's [ __ ] sitting
ducks right there you have no idea how
many people are drinking so you could
drink as much as you want parties shot I
don't give a [ __ ] but if you get behind
a wheel of a car Nigel got a problem man
okay because if you drive a car now
you're endangering others obviously
we're all familiar with mad Mothers
Against Drunk Driving
like you should have to pay the price
because you selfishly wanted to party
have a good time and now you're
endangering other people we all know
people that have gotten DUIs pulled over
but it's so puzzling these days when you
see a Paul Pelosi get a DUI when you see
a Tiger Woods get a DUI you see Justin
Bieber Lindsay Lohan famous DUIs out
there it's like have you not heard of
uber guys yeah like what are we talking
about here like the average person these
days can spend 20 30 40 50 bucks on an
Uber not going to be a problem now
you're talking Millionaires and
billionaires who are not willing to get
a goddamn uh Uber yeah it's insane to me
so harsher penalties for DUIs but you're
not going to limit people drinking you
never you don't think there's another
way to go with the study though like
that's a very small number of people
this says I think it said one in one in
six people are binge drinking the study
includes deaths with vehicular accidents
but including alcohol poisoning other
health impacts such as liver disease we
just came off record high overdoses
right Americans are overdosing they're
drinking too much they're overweight
everybody's on Xanax everybody's on
Zofran or whatever antidepressants when
are leadership and leaders are going to
wake up and say that there's something
wrong with America that we've lost our
way that we're not happy we're unhealthy
we're drinking ourselves to death we're
overdosing on drugs we're taken to like
you know there's something other than
just people going out and partying on a
Friday night right people are depressed
they're lost their mental health sucks
covet didn't help covet didn't help yeah
I mean if you want to thank you very
much thank you very much opioid crisis
with drinking and now you're talking
about two different problems that become
one obviously that gets ridiculously way
worse look you know there's two ways to
look at look at problems there's
Upstream problems and downstream
problems and what you just is correctly
pointed out the Upstream problem and
I've said this before here's an example
a small lake is polluted
the downstream problem is let's charge
all the people in this community 10
million dollars to build a giant filter
and clean a lake now the Upstream
problem is why don't we go up the stream
and find out what's polluting the lake
and we find that there's a campground
and there's ashes there's a lot of other
things going on up there and we say bye
if we just do a few things up here we
won't be putting crap in the Stream and
it won't be polluting the lake that is
correcting an upstream problem this is a
classic Downstream story States and
communities can prevent these using
reduce the availability let's call it
alcohol control it's like gun control we
if we control the guns we control the
alcohol we increase the price of it we
do all that that's Downstream the
question is why are the people drinking
why is there the demand for it or why
are there you know mentally deranged
people getting their hands on a firearm
those people shouldn't have a firearm
Upstream you brought it up the Upstream
problem is is America is a stressed out
overweight place and you know being
aware and helping your friends and I
identify that is how I deal with the
Upstream problem when I see friends or
family that I think are over stressed or
there because I don't want them to
self-medicate I don't want to do other
things and so it's a good point your
point is exactly right
that's a good point good commentary so
you know let's go to the last one and in
regards to DUIs by the way uh the
solution for not having one have a
person with you use Uber a lot of
feedback you give with Lyft now there's
no excuse for not having a DUI today
when I was in the army Sergeant told us
very simple if you guys going to go out
to the club and party someone's got to
be sober and God knows how many times
that rule was broken luckily none of us
we didn't get a DUI but other additional
challenges did take place especially
when companies like Budweiser are
offering free Designated Drivers so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]